merci à d'être avec tout d'un sur rt
français de nous apporter votre
éclairage alors tentative d'assassinât
du premier ministre alors que nous
sommes en pleines tractations
politiques en irak quelle lecture en
faites vous
aujourd'hui on parle de cet attentat qui
a visé le premier mis son chef du
gouvernement irakien monsieur moustache
academy mais on oublie que le terrorisme
c'est le quotidien des irakiens c'est le
quotidien des irakiens d'ailleurs les
médias occidentaux n'en parle plus
d'autres depuis longtemps j'étais à 2015
jeter à bagdad du sud irak que je n'ai
jamais vu dans ma vie des mesures de
sécurité si complexes comme celle que
j'ai vécue et je vu en irak malgré tout
cela la des attentats et le terrorisme
c'est le pain quotidien des arts x10
rakia il ya ce que nous appelons à
bagdad la zone vient la zone verte c'est
où ils vivent la nomenclatura les chefs
du parti politique le chef de
gouvernement les ministres etc le
président est là c'est super protégés
s'étaient c'était aussi c'était là-bas
le bastion des américains avant leur
retrait malgré tout seul le terrorisme
c'est le quotidien des irakiens pourquoi
pas ce qu'on dira qu'on a doublé crise
on à la crise d'état et la crise du
système politique la crise dit à sa date
depuis 2003 quand les américains envahi
l'irak ils ont cassé tout ils ont cassé
l'armée nationale irakienne qui était la
colonne vertébrale du logis ils ont des
racines et le parti baas alors le parti
baas est le seul parti laïc dans un lit
dans un irak où on trouve que les partis
islamistes que ce soit chiite ou sunnite
ils ont des racines et le parti baas
l'adoucir donc la dislocation de l'état
et et ils ont imposé le système
parlementaire aux irakiens nous savons
bien que les systèmes américains le sens
politique américain est un système
présidentiel absolue alors proposé un
système parlementaire et avec tout cela
il faut que le président soit kurdes le
chef du gouvernement soit chiite et le
chef du parlement soit asba sunnite ce
que n'avait pas pendant le règne du une
laïque de saddam aussi donc c'est les
problèmes on le voit aujourd'hui en
plein jour puisque l'âge de chaabi ne
n'accepte pas les résultats des
élections l'âge de chaabi pause qu'il ya
une fraude électorale massive
oui c'est de là d'ailleurs que son parti
des manifestations
oui absolument ils ont vu leur âge de
charité construit à l'époque j'ai
rencontré des chefs à tchad et d'autres
partis politiques évidemment s'est
construit contre dash parce que dash
appris le mot sur la deuxième grande
ville en irak puis à menacer bagdad
envahi barda bagdad donc il ya une
coalition d'aidé mais liste il ya une
coalition armée qui se nomme l'âge de
chaabi anachronique son travail en
luttant contre des shu en gagnant contre
dash mais les américains et leurs alliés
saoudienne on y pense que l'âge de
charles viii devenu très pro iranien
très peu on ya vu la population chiite
en irak y plus que 60 pensent on est
content digit de26 mal donc on peut
penser à l'influencé chiite aussi
éloignées et tout ça n'existait pas
pendant le régime laïque de basse de
saddam hussein mais à partir de 2003 on
parle maintenant des cures de disney et
des chiites alors on parle bien de la
coalition du reste elle cherbi qui
aurait perdu des sièges selon les
premiers résultats provisoires mais
finalement les gros blocs traditionnels
conservent leur représentation au
parlement
oui par exemple le bloc de moqtada sadr
et les toujours gagné dans d'autres
aussi mais ici nous savons bien que dans
les démocraties si grande partie quand
même qu'ils n'acceptent pas les
résultats on a un grand problème d'ordre
éthique d'ordre structurel est ce que
ces élections sont ont été justes
transparentes est ce qu'il ya eu une
fraude électorale comme l'ail des
chabbiha
réclame de toi de toute façon la
démocratie c'est ce fondé sur le
consensus et qu'il n'ya pas au consensus
malheureusement peut pas parler d'une
démocratie c'est pour cette raison que
je répète toujours honnête hoa système
parlementaire dans le monde arabe qui
sont dans l'impasse totale le système et
raquil du système parlementaire irakien
de systèmes parlementaires tunisiens le
système parlementaire libanais les 310
république donc on voit bien qu on a un
grand problème avec le système
parlementaire dans le monde arabe
d'ailleurs même je pense depuis
occidentaux ils sont issus problème
alors monsieur si des liens très très
rapidement il faudra bien ces élections
des statuts du mois d'octobre était
prévue pour 2022 elles ont finalement
été avancée par le premier ministre pour
répondre à la colère populaire des
irakiens un peuple aujourd'hui quand
lamar
oui évidemment
évidemment il ya eu la corruption et la
compétition reine est vraiment en irak
ce que m'ont dit les irakiens et comme
josé dit aussi le régime raquel et el
haïk aujourd'hui on parle que des
groupes hostiles et cela mr kurdes
chiites sunnites ce qui n'existait pas
avant 2003 et là il s'implique très
enrichissant le paradoxe l'irak si c'est
la deuxième réserve je pense dans le
monde c'est un pays exportateur dé
pétrole c'est à pic elle nourrit cette
recette pétrole de pétrodollars colossal
malgré tout ça malgré tout cela envoie
la pauvreté en irak or voient le
tiers-monde en irak on voit des
quartiers qui sont qui vivent la misère
donc il ya ici une manifestation
pacifique et d'ailleurs si contre toutes
les élites politiques les irakiens se
manifestent contre tous les partis
politiques quant aux toutes les élites
politiques qui les accusent d'être
corrompu qui ne servent pas et qui ne
sont pas au service de la population
mais pour l'enrichissement personnel
riadh sidaoui remercie 1 n'a pas répondu
à nos questions je rappelle vous êtes
expert du monde arabe et directeur du
karabakh merci à vous